[Musik]
ich wollte ihn nicht länger als 37
schlafen
wo bist du gerade
ich mache jedes mal mit sander termin
waren wir der neue podcast folge
aufnehmen und sie ist jedes mal nicht zu
hause sondern bei wem anders aus regnet
das ganz neu sind an bord man denken von
meiner wasserflasche ist und das bett
gekullert herzlich willkommen zum besten
blocker der welt die scheiße ist halt
jetzt ist es 38 und ich bin ich ganz
normal zu schlafen aber die mannschaft
bauen da oben jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal duschen
[Musik]
ich habe plane liebe freunde ich jedoch
nicht als er ich gehe doch als erstes du
schon so wie ich aussehe
ich bin im spiel gegen freunde und wir
haben jetzt eine mission
ich hätte nie gedacht das ist jetzt mal
sagte aber ich mache mir jetzt einen
kaffee tasse kaffee habe an meine eltern
meine kleine kaffeemaschine geschenk von
daher let's go feuerwehr weil ich so
heißt die antwort ist nein und mir nun
allerdings die demission für euch meine
lieben freuen und zwar ist das hier das
soll der gerät die laundry würdet ihr
longhi das nicht kapiert italienischen
den long gehen sondern sich auch den
höheren wie machen wir das jetzt bruder
eine mama wäre auf jeden fall so
komische kapseln hier gegeben also
espressobar sie habe aus um milchtüte
geben also alles für einen kaffee hätte
ich glaube ich damit zu den espresso das
halt so in grafs alter kenne diese leute
dann so klein dass presse einfach
wegstecken wir den scheiß hier erstmal
die steckdose
[Musik]
auf deutsch sitzt den ganzen apparat
leider h so vermeiden die risiken die
tödlichen stromschlag und wir lassen es
mit dem café jetzt haben sogar ein
stellt das essen vorher an bevor ich mit
den chefs kaffee gemacht habe ich bin
echt so ein technik amateur aber ich
etwas raus gefunden und zwar kann ich
das hochklappen
wir sehen uns allen drei tagen durch
mein café ab
gute idee
ich bin sehr offen welcher kingsley das
ist mein kaffee oder was wir uns mal bis
7000 vergangen bei der liebe freunde ich
habe gerade hier meine letzten block
geschnitten
ich hasse diese kamera der focus money
bester blocker er ist auf jeden fall
steht die sonne jetzt schon relativ tief
das merkt nicht wie dieses wohl tief und
das heißt ich habe heute bisher original
gar nichts geschafft ich habe bei video
geschnitten aber mehr nicht
muss also voll viele wohnungs krankheit
noch machen und zwar erstmal jetzt meine
komischen internet repeater anschließen
weil meine wohnung ist 7000 quadratmeter
großen hat man leute ich komme aber auch
nicht glaube technik ich muss irgendwie
diese beiden teile das sind irgendwie so
von apple
dann kannst du dateien darauf speichern
und das auch noch mehr internet weiß
gießen leitung stehen das dauert drei
minuten mit zwei stunden hatte bis
dunkel draußen bin ich dumm oder sind
die anderen aber ist frust lassen
ich habe es geschafft hätte dass ein
handwerker wollte zu hause sind und egal
was ihr macht ihr fühlt euch bei allem
einfach dumm und fehl am platz ich
dachte dann halt auch wenn jetzt die
handwerker herum kommen dann hole ich
den halt zumindest bietet an können ihr
wissen was trinken wäre die arbeiten da
wollte man sehen wie viel von dem bier
getrunken wurde gar nix außerdem habe
ich auch hier in meiner hamburger
wohnung mir eine wand wie auch in köln
mit tafel farbe streichen das ist dass
alle meine freunde dort drauf und
schreiben können ihr seht ich habe mir
viele freunde ich glaube der glaube ist
sehr extrem langweilig weil ich den
ganzen tag hier nur in meiner wohnung
hänge und so neuen wohnung schrittmacher
von daher lasse ich euch jetzt nur ich
geschlafen und morgen früh muss ich noch
freundin beim babysitten helfen da sehen
wir uns wieder zwei fun facts am morgen
ich bin müde und ich stelle halteverbot
stehen hier noch mal ich war grad
babysitten hat dabei entspannt nahezu
gar nichts gefilmt ja ich bin profi
blockhaft das baby hatten es muss
gefilmt
[Musik]
hollywood karriere incamail ich glaube
ich dass sein wird auf jeden fall kaufen
der kaufen sagen ich habe mich für den
vfb entschieden
das glaube ich super für saucen ich
wollte mich mal wieder komplett belagern
lassen jetzt weiter gekauft vier töpfen
toaster haben noch zwei untersetzer 700
euro
eine allgemeine verkehrskontrolle mit
ihnen machen
ich habe übrigens megacool gläser für
meine wohnung in hamburg bestellt jetzt
bin ich gerade zum ersten mal in einem
gläser geschäft um csl war die dritte
sprachen lernen
ich wohne jetzt seit einer woche in
hamburg einfach jeden morgen mit the
jams nicht sponsor aber weiter laden
gutes motiv habe selbst das sagen wenn
du werbung machen willst du machen jetzt
froh willkommen in der hölle und das war
sehr schön
[Musik]
wie wird das wetter am morgen haben wir
gewartet teilweise bewölkten himmel
morgen die höchsttemperaturen sich bei
18 grad und die tiefsttemperaturen
liegen
[Musik]
wie viel regnet mors
das war jetzt mein fünfter oder sechster
abend hier in hamburg war auf jeden fall
einer der lustigsten weil waren einfach
bei ihm komplett normalen italiener und
es ist einfach so witzig mit guten
freunden einfach den besitzer kennen
gelernt ist etwas gegessen bisschen was
getrunken jetzt will ich hier nicht müde
und es ist drei uhr 44 94 stunden sind
handwerker weiter
wir sehen uns morgen wieder als ich muss
mal gucken weil seitdem ich mir diese
drei vier wochen pause gegönnt habe habe
ich mir einfach gesagt ich will einfach
das film und das aufnehmen worauf ich
einfach selber bock habt und gerade habe
ich einfach bock darauf die kamera
mitzunehmen es ist zwar nie etwas
krasses so dass ich fett herumreißt oder
keine ahnung also ich bin hier in neun
städten unterwegs aber vielleicht
gefällt
wir dürfen
die tage wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]